salut à tous Bienvenue chez envergure on
poursuit notre série de podcasts pour
présenter les candidats à la draft
2023 ce qu'on veut faire c'est en 20
minutes vous donner l'essentiel vous
donner à savoir qui est un joueur quels
sont ses principales qualités et comment
on peut le projeter en NBA aujourd'hui
on vous donne le profil d'Amen Thompson
Amel Thompson né le 30 janvier 2003 il
aura donc il a donc déjà 20 ans à
l'heure à laquelle on enregistre il aura
20 ans le soir de la draft également de
mettre 0,1 environ
97 kg selon les mensurations du NBA
combine qui s'est tenu au mois de mai de
mettre 10 d'envergure peut-être même un
peu plus plutôt un meneur arrière il
joue avec lovertime Elite ces deux
dernières années c'est pour ceux qui
n'ont pas suivi une ligue de
développement pour donc financer par
overtime et c'est fait pour les joueurs
prédithmes de lycée mais ils peuvent
être grâce à ça
rémunéré donc c'est à théoriquement
avant la NCM même si pour amen Thompson
ça a remplacé la NCA pour parler d'Amen
Thompson notre spécialiste overtime
Elite c'est Yassine salut Yassine salut
Alex
et donc Thomas qui est là également et
qui a bien suivi le parcours d'Amen
exactement salut à tous
on commence toujours par un portrait une
biographie
quel est le parcours d'hamment Thompson
c'est toi qui t'en charge Thomas
alors en même temps comme tu l'as dit en
début d'année 2003 donc il est assez
vieux pour sa classe comme comme son
frère jumeau aux arts donc et Brandon
Miller si les joueurs assez vieux de
cette classe donc c'est un jeu qui vient
de côte du côté donc land il vient de
Californie donc il a un grand il a une
famille de sportif il a un grand frère
qui a joué en division en NCA après
review son frère donc Troyes Thompson
qui est un bon shooter chez allé à
l'arrêt check say il est à 38% sur deux
saisons sur 5 tentatives formats donc
cette différence un peu des deux jumeaux
son oncle est également est également
grand sportif Mark Thomson il a
représenté il a Jamaïque aux 400 mètres
au JO de Barcelone en 92 une bonne
vitesse dans la famille donc son son
père a décidé de les mettre vraiment
dans le basket très très tôt ils ont
commencé à s'entraîner vraiment assez
rapidement dès 7 ans donc son père les a
vraiment mis en condition pour pour
devenir des vrais joueurs donc assez tôt
également vers 10 12 années c'est
parents des idées qui fasse l'école à la
maison donc avec son frère Rosa pour
perfectionner leur niveau scolaire mais
également passer du bon temps pour
améliorer améliorer pardon leur
développement tant comme également et
c'est de la randonner et des
entraînements c'est de s'améliorer
spirituellement culturellement également
notamment avec leur grand-père Claude
Wilson et ce moyen de fonctionner leur
permettait de passer beaucoup de temps
également à s'améliorer au basket donc
très tôt le basket est une énorme place
dans leur vie ensuite nous utilisons ils
ont déménagé en Floride et du coup ils
ont rejoint une High School en Florée de
l'icechool de pagne Crest en Floride ils
ont été des joueurs majeurs rapidement
et le final de tout ça c'est donc leur
troisième année d'High School il
remporte le championnat d'état dans ce
match là c'est un match assez important
pour la carrière notamment Thompson qui
43 points dans un match en double
prolongation et il est réduit un gros
déficitant en fin de match alors que ça
aurait été lui exclu il est de joueurs
sont élus coplayer of the Year c'est
vraiment des joueurs qui sont
inséparables dans leur parcours les deux
joueurs ont donc décidé de rejoindre
l'overtime pour se préparer au mieux
pour la NBA et donc ça fait deux ans qui
se font en over time élite donc cette
fille que tu as présenté que ta
présentée Alex donc tu me dis pas et du
côté d'Atlanta où ils ont évolué depuis
deux ans désormais
merci Thomas pour pour le parcours
maintenant on va essayer de voir quel
était le rôle d'Amen cette année j'ai
dit plutôt porteur de balles quel était
le contexte on va pas parler du contexte
qui pourrait avoir en NBA j'ai oublié de
mentionner à son propos et c'est
important il est 5e dans notre bigboard
sa deuxième version amène Thomson 4e
chez ispn chez zyatletic chez the Ringer
on l'a vu parfois numéro 3 chez nous je
pense qu'en début de l'année il était
peut-être numéro 3 il a glissé un petit
peu il y a quelques doutes sur le niveau
de l'overtime notamment parce que il
jouait contre des joueurs plus jeunes
que lui alors qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
cette saison
Yassine c'est toi c'est toi qui est
chargé de cette partie qui est le quel
rôle cette année pour amen Thompson avec
l'outil i à son rôle très simple c'était
le leader de son équipe le capitaine le
meneur titulaire porteur de balle
il a tourna du 16 points si rebond 6 à 6
de style et un bloc en 27 minutes durant
la saison régulière
puis on ne verte Émilie tu as eu les
play-offs qu'ils ont gagné d'ailleurs où
il a tourné à du 17 points 9 à 6-7
rebonds en 35 minutes de temps de jeu
quasiment tout le temps sur le terrain
il a tourné à 66% proche du cercle sur
neuf tentatives sont à trois points plus
en difficulté où il a tourné à 25% sur
seulement trois tentatives par match
son volume de tir et pas conséquent il a
il prend 11 tirs par match 56% de
réussite
il va pour un joueur qui va très souvent
au cercle il va 4 fois sur la ligne des
lancer francs où il tourne à 65%
, c'est pas si terrible que ça
et quand tu dis meneur titulaire c'est
quel genre de meneur est-ce que c'est le
meneur gestionnaire qui met le ballon
sous le bras est-ce que c'est un gars
qui drive un peu des deux il peut être
un playmaker il peut faire jouer ses
coéquipiers et il peut driver avec son
premier pas explosif et aller au cercles
et sa source de scoring c'est souvent un
proche du cercle
c'est aussi un jour positif pour son
équipe quand un garçon plus minus
constamment positif
une bonne mentalité
ok le rôle donc cette année de amen qui
était dans la même équipe que son frère
jumeau sont des vrais jumeaux
monozygotes
Thompson qui fait l'objet d'un autre
épisode si vous voulez écouter
[Musique]
quel est son ticket d'entrée ça c'est le
déroulement de ses podcasts de
présentation maintenant on se demande si
je draft ce joueur demain si je suis
gmnb pourquoi je le fais Thomas à ton
avis c'est quoi qu'est-ce qu'on se dit
quand on draft amen Thompson
grave ta main Thomson car si on part de
Victor one bagnama comme najor
générationnel
amène Thomson on en est un en quelque
sorte aussi des athlètes comme lui on en
aura pas assez que très rarement en NBA
et donc c'est sa principale carte
d'entrée en NBA c'est que c'est le
meilleur athlète de cette race un
athlète juste ahurissant comme on en
voit très rarement et couplé à ça c'est
également pour moi le meilleur patient
de cette draft donc un combo playmating
qualitat un niveau exceptionnel
qu'est-ce qui te qu'est-ce qui te fait
dire ce qu'on peut développer le côté
athlète qui est quelle partie
véritablement de ses capacités
athlétiques de laisse voilà en toi
alors premièrement déjà nous poursons
pas comme on me l'a dit c'est un meneur
de jeu un Mordor de jeu donc porteur de
balle qui joue principalement
ballonnement qui a besoin de la balle
pour pour jouer pour être positif pour
son équipe et donc pour rapporteur de
balle il est déjà très grand comme on
l'a dit il fait 2 mètres il a une très
grande envergure il a déjà une frame
très solide il fait 97 kg donc c'est
vraiment il a déjà encore complètement
prêt pour la NBA en plus de ça donc il a
un premier pas juste ahurissant et ma
première passe super tonique il peut
global n'importe quel défenseur ça lui
permet d'être un genre de transition
fabule également il avalait les espaces
et vu que c'est un pompe playmaker
défensif on en reparlera après il peut
très facilement partir en transition et
sur demi-terreur comme je l'ai dit peu
global quasiment n'importe quel joueur
ça lui permet également de jouer du pit
and roll à très haut volume avec cette
avance athlétique qu'il a sur n'importe
quel joueur et l'aura également NBA il
arrive dans une bière c'est un top top
10 top 5 même peut-être top 3 voir plus
plus athlète NBA c'est vraiment un
athlète commun et en plus de ça donc il
a une détente une détente d'exception
également que ce soit au niveau du hang
time donc il va rester énormément de
temps en l'air ça va lui permettre de
d'avoir définition très acrobatique et
très imprévisible il peut mettre
beaucoup de pression sur le cercle donc
grâce à toutes ces qualités grâce à sa
vitesse grâce à sa taille grâce à son
explosivité un énorme premier pas il est
capable aussi de très très bien
décélérer un petit peu aller de 0 à 100
en 2 secondes il peut mettre d'un coup
le pied sur le frein notamment avec des
eurostles qui va le permettre de finir
plus plus en contrôle dans le trafic
donc c'est vraiment un athlète comme on
envoie rarement dans tous les sens du
terme que c'est au niveau de la taille
de la vitesse de l'explosivité de la
détente il a le package complet du
joueur ultra atlétique en NBA pour sa
position tu as des trucs à ajouter sur
ce que vient de dire Thomas sur ce côté
athlétique peut-être sur le côté
playmaker qu'est-ce que tu as vu de lui
qui sont tout à l'heure tu me disais il
peut il peut vous faire jouer les autres
qu'est-ce que précisément si on entre
dans la précision des skills qu'est-ce
qui t'a impressionné
il a pour moi un très bon Haendel ce qui
lui permet de bien voyager et de trouver
ses coéquipiers facilement il peut jouer
du driven kick trouver ses coéquipiers
au périmètre
avoir l'accès l'accessibilité au travail
facilement
pour moi c'est un très très bon
playmaker gestionnaire gère le tempo
accélère quand il faut
il a toutes les qualités enfin
un peu trop précipité par moment mais en
devenir ça peut être un très bon
clémaker on va toucher les du doigt le
développement
que qu'il pourrait avoir messieurs parce
que
c'est ce qui est intéressant maintenant
qu'on a donné son ticket d'entrée
qu'est-ce qui va faire qu'est-ce qui
peut faire de lui vraiment un super
joueur c'est quoi le truc qui peut être
déclic Yassine à ton avis
pour moi il peut être un mais enfin un
joueur très fort joueur s'il arrive à
gérer sa sélection de ça sélection de
Drive de pas toujours aller au cercle et
finir de manière précipitée
donc c'est sélection de tir et pour moi
ça ça défense on parle pas assez de sa
défense mais il a athlétique les
puissant explosif il peut devenir un
très très fort défenseur et sans NBA il
y en a on en a toujours besoin
je pense qu'il peut défendre sur les
postes extérieurs ça c'est sûr et
pourquoi pas le
post-4 jusqu'au poste 4 pourquoi pas
avoir mais pour moi ça défend ça peut
être un atout
tu peux lui faire
et tu dis c'est à développer parce que
pour l'instant c'était pas tout le temps
le cas il était un peu inconstant
défensivement il a un peu de tête en
l'air il pense plus à attaquer que
défendent alors qu'il a des outils
incroyables
les moins concentrés de défensivement
que son frère en tout cas
aux art Thomson
qui est plus reconnu effectivement pour
être le meilleur défenseur des deux je
précise quand même que les les deux ont
pris du poids dans l'année puisque nous
on les avait autour de 92 93 kg amène
Thompson tu as 92 kg il se ramène en NBA
combine à 97 kg
ça c'est la force de overtime Mélite
c'est de donner des infrastructures
aussi très très
d'excellentes qualités assez joueur même
si niveau de jeu était pas fou donc ça
lui a permis et franchement à 97 kg de
mètres 0,1 de mètres 10 11 d'envergure
effectivement tu as raison je pense
qu'il pourrait si il s'en donne les
moyens défendre sur des postes 4
autre autre skill clé à développer
Thomas pour moi c'est clairement amène
Thompson c'est clairement une globalité
je vais pas parler de son tir ça
pourrait être l'évidence mais je pense
qu'on est beaucoup trop loin du compte
pour penser qu'ils puissent vraiment
développer un tyran une bière en tout
cas je le draft pas pour ça encore cette
année c'est moins de 25% sur un faible
volume à 3 points la mécanique et
clairement encore très bancal il y a une
amélioration importante au lancer cette
année c'est important de le dire c'est
un peu mieux mécaniquement il est passé
de 52% l'an passé ce qui est vraiment
dramatique à 68% toute compétition avec
les matchs de précession cette année
donc ça devient plus décent mais pour
moi amène Thomson ça sa principale et sa
grande force dans son développement
c'est pour moi qu'il a rien besoin
d'ajouter en fait dans son jeu pour moi
il a déjà tous les styles pour être le
joueur qui peut devenir il a déjà la
défense il a déjà le Haendel et il a
déjà le drive il a déjà le playmaking il
a touché à la finition au cercle il a
déjà tout mais tout doit être clean il
est encore beaucoup de déchets un peu
partout en défense comme l'a dit Yassine
il a encore un peu trop tête en l'air
malgré ça à plus de deux interceptions
par match plus d'un compte c'est-à-dire
que la vie c'est super priorité
athlétique qu'il aura toujours un billet
et ça peut être un playmaker défensif
assez dingue en une pièce je pense
encore car il a ce sens des lignes de
passe il peut faire du rotation en
cercle de très différentes manières il
peut ça peut être un log down sur
l'homme sur au moins les postes 1 2 3
très clairement parce que il est
tellement rapide d'appui tellement long
tellement intense qui peut être vraiment
très très compliqué à passer il a mis
des gens présents vraiment cette année
et pour moi donc comme c'est vraiment ça
va être vraiment son jeu et un Coran
trop de pertes de balles dans le trop de
perte de balles dans les pastes des pas
encore trop apprécié malgré qu'il soit
capable de passer exceptionnel il fait
des passes personnellement j'avais
jamais vu ça je rappelle de pas c'est
fait 360 dans le corner il fait vraiment
des choses allez regarder Thomson il
fait vraiment des choses qu'on doit
nulle part ailleurs donc c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment ça peut être efficace
mais c'est vraiment le spectacle la
beauté la beauté du jeu et donc on a un
joueur qui va devoir cléner un peu tout
son jeu et si juste il arrive à avoir
moins de déchets et plus régulier dans
ses finitions vraiment donc tu as
continué de bien travailler on sait
qu'il a une éthique de travail très
importante on l'a dit depuis ces 7 8 ans
et les conditionner également par ses
parents pour cet avenir de genre de
basket professionnel donc s'il continue
à très bien travailler à bien cadrer un
peu plus se poser parfois sur de mes
terrains comme il y a signe l’évoquer
des fois ils ont un peu trop à 100 à
l'heure un peu comme un Jaden Ivy par
exemple l'an dernier si il arrive à se
calmer à bien à bien cadrer ses skills
entre guillemets et juste à peaufiner ce
qu'il a déjà en magasin je pense que ça
peut devenir un joueur exceptionnel
personnellement donc c'est ça que
j'adore chez lui c'est qu'il a pas
besoin d'en rajouter je pense dans son
jeu est-ce que on a l'exemple je vous
demander de penser à des peut-être des
comparaisons ou au moins des
comparaisons dans le rôle puisqu'on va
arriver sur le rôle probable pour lui
l'année prochaine mais Thomas ce qu'on a
des exemples de joueurs qui sont aussi
mauvais au tir et qui réussissent en NBA
je pense que c'est vraiment dur de tirer
des comparaisons avec les qu'on peut
dire oui il y a pas de joueur aussi
mauvais au tir qui réussissent en NBA
mais si on a déjà vu des joueurs aussi
athlétiques et aussi bon passeur NBA je
ne suis pas sûr donc c'est vraiment ça
va vraiment attendre de nouveaux cas
unique et je pense qu'il faut pas
projeter en même temps comme étant le
franchise player d'une équipe à 25 26
ans de Maurienne vu que mettre 25 points
de moyenne sans avoir d'eau chaude en
NBA à part Giani santé de compo qu'il
fait il y a pas grand monde donc c'est
vraiment compliqué mais amène Thomson
n'a pas besoin de ça pour être un joueur
fabuleux je pense que ces qualités de
Drive c'est qu'elle était transition on
améliorant son touché vu comme on l'a
dit on touche un corps très irrégulier
mais il est capable de finition des deux
mains main droite main gauche avec son
intime vraiment d'exception comme son
frère
donc il est vraiment capable de grandes
choses et si clean tout ça il peut être
capable de tourner à plus de 15 à
approcher les 20 points par match je
pense NBA et si il arrive à être à 16 17
points par match NBA qui les présents
rebond qu'il a 5 6 rebond qui peut être
à 7 8 9 passes par match plus qui
l'amène une défense de très haut niveau
avec ses qualités athlétiques sa science
de la défense etc ça peut être un genre
vraiment très complet et un meneur un
meneur vraiment différent qu'apporte des
choses assez incroyable donc beaucoup de
domaines du jeu sauf au shoot bien sûr
rôle probable l'année prochaine
rapidement Thomas qu'est-ce qu'elle sera
meneur pure meneur deuxième arrière
ce qui fait ce qu'on va lui donner la
balle
pour l'instant il a toujours joué
ballonnement depuis qu'il est petit
c'est sans shooter la balle en main pour
être pour être positif sinon il pourrait
changer un peu plus comme son frère
comme un short de cut sauf qu'il a pas
du tout le shoot de son frère pour
l'instant donc pour jouer c'est plus
compliqué moi j'aimerais faut qu'on lui
donne des répétitions il a déjà 20 ans
mais je pense que c'est un joueur qui
qui va avoir besoin de temps il a aussi
une grosse échelle à passer la plupart
des gens vont essayer de NCA ou de
l'étranger à la NBA lui il passe d'un
niveau quasiment High School à la NBA
donc il a vraiment un step à franchir il
va peut-être se prendre un mur au début
et ça va pouvoir lui faire du bien
également pour pour continuer de
progresser pour réussir à passer ces
étapes donc moi je pense qu'il doit
avoir la balle en main faut lui donner
des répétitions si on draft amène
Thompson c'est qu'on croit en projet
donc si on croit en ce projet faut lui
donner la balle pour qu'il continue de
progresser tout simplement je dis pas
qu'il y a deux jours de manière 35
mètres par match mais doit clairement
avoir des répétitions ballonnements le
plus rapidement NBA pour qu'il continue
de progresser je pense
conclusion Yassine est-ce que est-ce que
tu crois et pourquoi
ses qualités pour moi deviennent élites
si on arrive à le faire progresser je
j'y crois parce que l'important
l'impotentiel de fou alors que si ses
qualités voilà c'est un jour moyen d'un
bien je le vois j'ai du mal à le voir
s'imposer c'est un peu parce que la pâte
tire donc je pense que c'est qualité
doit être élites pour qu'ils deviennent
un jour solide
intéressant Thomas tu on a bien compris
que tu croyais toi moi j'y crois il est
3e de mon board comme je l'ai dit il
faut vraiment qu'il maximise les
qualités qu'il a déjà moi je me
préoccupe pas du tir je pense qu'il en a
pas besoin pour valoir ce pick 3 donc si
il arrive à maximiser ses qualités avec
son éthique de travail avec un bon
développement je pense que c'est
possible donc je pense qu'il a toutes
les cartes en main pour devenir à terme
un super joueur indien donc oui je crois
vraiment même si au vu de son profil au
vu que son manque quasiment total de
shoot il y a forcément des risques ça
reste implique risqué mais j'y crois dur
comme faire absolument un pic risqué et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on ce qu'on
entend discutant avec certains scouts
un pic risqué que soit lui ou son jumeau
même si aux arts un peu plus à droite
cette année c'est quand même pas ça
il y a des doutes sur ça sur le niveau
d'overtime Elite il faut le dire quand
même que si amène Thomson n'est pas
choisi dans le top 5 6 de cette draft ça
va être très compliqué pour overtime
Elite de continuer d'attirer des gros
prospects ils en ont encore pour des
années prochaines quelques-uns mais ça
va devenir compliqué après déjà l'échec
l'année dernière de j'en Monteiro Me
drasté Dominique Barlow non plus donc
c'est c'est ça joue gros en fait du côté
d'overtime avec cette draft et je ne
sais pas si ça peut jouer dans le fait
qu'une équipe prenne ou non mais en tout
cas c'est un des enjeux de la draft
d'Amen Thompson merci Thomas merci
Yacine on se retrouve pour trouver tous
nos podcasts sur Deezer sur Spotify sur
Youtube aussi sur Google podcast
normalement vous êtes obligé de nous
trouver les scouting report les articles
c'est sur envergure.co vous avez une
fiche pour chaque prospect avec très
souvent voilà des scouting report force
faiblesses améliorer et résumer écrit de
ce qu'on vient de vous dire c'était
l'essentiel sur amen Thompson Ciao